do you think most girls think that
they're hotter than they are
oh wow
for the for the man
i'll say this carefully um look i think
people in general have uh great
difficulty being objective about how
they look i think
okay women
do you think no well i think men less so
to be honest with you if i'm if i'm
being i'm trying to be as diplomatic as
possible yeah but
look truthfully
i think men don't really have
uh the same kind of
uh problems with objectives excuse me
like for example myself
if i were to you know like rate myself
or whatever i'd probably give myself
somewhere around like a four or a five
maybe even less depending on who's
observing the reason why i say that and
the reason why i say that's an objective
rating
we could take into consideration height
skin color ethnicity
uh
some people might like facial hair some
people don't i'm growing bold you know
it's happening my dad's bored you know
like that might take a couple of points
off for some people or it might increase
who knows but i've got to accept that
as a as a man yeah i've got to accept my
station the fact that maybe i was less
blessed genetically than others or more
blessed genetically than others or
whatever
and i've got to just do what i can to
improve i feel as though women
regardless of whether they're big small
tall dark white whatever
there's a sense of like
i'm i i deserve
some kind of like a high-value man or a
high-value partner or whatever like
hence why you were talking about the 820
rule why the majority vast majority of
women go for the same couple of dudes
yeah so there is a sense of entitlement
there
if you're all going for the same guys
not all of you are going to get the same
guys obviously so some of you guys need
to kind of
take stock and be like well
maybe i'm not cut out for that kind of
guy
or whatever you know let me find someone
in my station in my wheelhouse in my
category
so what about you what do you think
there everything on our dad is um why do
girls think all their friends are hot
all of my friends are hot i attract
people talking to the bike
oh yeah um yeah i just think that's uh
that's uh evidence that girls don't
think judge themselves accordingly to
how they look i do um could you answer
could you ask the question again so the
question is do you think most girls
think they're hotter than they are yes
why
i think it comes from
a group mentality where like within
their group they may
tell themselves things that are not true
but to comfort their feelings so then
they get the sense of entitlement that
they
deserve this and they
deserve that um
but it's
it's females in general it's not it's
not a
it's not it's not something that i'd say
oh like
this is
a bad i think it is a bad thing to be
honest actually um
yeah
now let's hear from the girls do you
think most girls are objective or do you
think they think they're hotter than
they are or do they underrate themselves
go around personally i think it depends
on the person because growing up i'm
obviously not skinny hi everyone i'm not
skinny so growing up i was never the
beauty standard for anyone so like all
my friends were getting chatted up by
people blah blah blah blah and i was
just the other one you know so like i
never really thought of myself as
an attractive person like i would never
call myself anything more than a thought
but
now like i don't really care about
what anyone thinks about me like i've
grown into myself and i've i've i'm
comfortable with who i am now that like
even if you guys call me delusion or
whatever i think i'm
maybe not a ten let's not go that far
but
like definitely an eight
so like
whether you guys think i am or not
yeah that's got nothing to do with her
but like what is it that took you from a
four to an eight if nothing's changed
what is it that takes loving myself and
and looking in the mirror and not being
disgusted at what i see i understand
that yeah so
but that doesn't you're not necessarily
being objective about how other people
view you right because isn't that what a
rating really is like what you think the
vast majority like like if i rated
myself one to ten i give myself a five i
think i'm normal looking and i just
think it's based on my results i think
if i was an eight nine or ten i would
have had modeling contracts because
people in the top 20 of beauty they get
they get modeling contracts
so what what is beauty i mean there's a
lot of things like if you
i mean you can you can go online and
have people rate your pictures and they
they rank you one to ten that's wild and
and so you can get you can get a lot of
data that says how attractive you are in
society and men will wait you women will
rate you like every day
how we look is like how we represent
ourselves it's not fun but it's just
like being honest
so
um and it's also like you can take get
dating apps to like you know everyone's
tinder bumble like they have a ranking
for you behind the scenes
yeah damn yeah well
so
um
i don't understand when girls say like
i'm an eight because or sometimes i hear
girls who say time because i hear this a
lot where they say like because i love
myself and i'm like confident now but
don't you think attractiveness is based
on results
they may be but i don't care about those
results
to be honest
but do you think then you're not being
objective
about your how attractive you are or how
attractive anyone else might be
i guess not but i think yeah
that stuff's not really important to me
yeah
i think when when someone
when someone rates
somebody
why why does that have anything to do
with them like if you rate me if someone
rated like somebody or three and it's
just like okay that's that's your
opinion like it's not like a rating is
not a fact it's an opinion
what do you know what i mean everyone's
opinion then well
yeah add up to a consensus maybe not a
fact yeah consensus yeah
yeah but i think
like i i have a group of friends right
and when i walk into the room with the
group of friends i know immediately
who's going to get the most attention
from the guys it's it's not me right i
have like a friend who's like very very
attractive and i know when i walk into a
room with her like the guys talk to her
first because like girls you can kind of
just feel it but i almost
wonder when i hear like and i hear this
from girls a lot like i'm a 10 i'm a 10
i'm a tent
um
if that's not like rooted in reality
because attractiveness like there's
numbers behind it whether it's just your
results in the world or your dating app
data or
the like the type of guys you can get
it was quite harsh yeah this is a tough
one it's not fun like
i don't enjoy like walking into a room
and knowing everyone's going to talk to
my friend and not me that's not fun
but i think i'd be delusional if i if i
thought if i walked into a room and i
thought
wow like they're all going to talk to me
first
i think in addition to your point men
understand hierarchy i was just gonna
say that so we understand that
i'm a four because there are guys that
are five i can get this attention guys
there are six they get that attention
seven and so on and so forth whereas
women um i don't want to say they live
in a delusion sometimes but it's a case
of
well i
because i believe i'm this i am that and
i was gonna speak about gender but i
thought let me not because
there's a whole separate topic where
people will go oh
what is gender
and then yeah yeah yeah let's not go
into that yeah that's not going to that
face you're going to get me in trouble
but i think i do think that women also
understand hierarchy it's just like
in this day and age
because we've been exposed to what men
want
we kind of understand like oh okay
that's not what men want but i don't
care because i'm not i'm never going to
be that you know
without
money
and and clout